hello freak [ __ ] I have never seen a
single silly statement like I could kill
a wolf what I was getting so much
[ __ ] bike that's the wheel if you
were so excited about this it's the
weirdest thing I've ever seen man I
can't I can't call it it was a clear
ending [ __ ] all the time and that just
for some reason that uh
everybody had an opinion or that's a
weird one man funny though I've seen a
lot of people tweet really ridiculous
[ __ ] but I don't think I've ever seen
anything get this much speculation
discussion debate people are mad at you
because like [ __ ] you you can't can't be
the wolf again I do Christ
know what kind of man do ya it is a
weird thing man it's a weird thing it
does the social media today it must you
know what I think it is I think you said
it at a time where people were looking
for some [ __ ] to argue that has nothing
to do with Trump nothing to do with you
climate change you're like oh we got
something here
come on out here I'm glad I could be
their source of notoriety right hey MIT
yeah it does seem like that though
doesn't it's like you caught like I
think it's like Peaks and waves because
if you did this always today 9/11 happen
nobody would give a [ __ ] it probably you
don't you know respect it probably yeah
exactly but I can't believe you're doing
this on that day some people probably if
you did it today to go it can't believe
you said it on national ohms day bro
yeah first national Woman's Day what
you're talking about fighting wolf this
is what's wrong with man he would look
just wrong with the patriarchy I can't
call it man that's it it was interesting
though my mom calling me hilarious man
people I talked to for years but it
can't be the Wolf River I don't know man
I don't know now when you Lee said the
[ __ ] about wolves right how serious were
you do you have serious [ __ ] around
well I mean I was half [ __ ] around
but it's like when you start thinking
about it and breaking it down I really I
feel like I can like uh everybody thinks
like I'm talking about Slayer by
especially on Twitter you they're
posting these big-ass wolves with the
two hundred pounds plus
what I'm like I listen tonight those are
rare right right
I'm not the biggest human on earth and
you gonna give me a picture of the
biggest wolf you can find like that's
not some fair it's not fair right so
google average wolf size and I feel like
if it was you know my life was dependent
on it like you have to think like that
right if you run into a wolf and he's
threatening you and you like I can't get
him you day so well I feel like if you
had something on you you'd have more of
a chance I would have the nerve of a
knife something yeah I feel like I don't
I wouldn't be in the woods without
something but wolves man do you know how
hard they bite ya know I've done a
little research I've done a little
research
um I think like twelve hundred five
times stronger than a pit bull right all
right I think it's 2,500
I think it's 2,500 pounds per square
inch see if you finally look in
yesterday yeah I think it said of a
mastiff was stronger than a wolf which
is weird it wasn't it wasn't it on top
well I'd [ __ ] about our alligators
crocodiles were stronger than that a
gorilla was stronger so the Grylls bites
from in you Wow
I would've never imagined I heard below
that look at up here Ian yeah they're
eating broccoli and [ __ ] I mean strong
branches again well they just have to
fight other gorillas for pudding
because I have never won in chicken a
they control a bunch of chicks I'd have
to have a good bite how do you know that
they have one I know I should what girls
that is a real tiny egg experiment where
we live in the day men the thing you
have going for you is that a wolf
doesn't really want to fight to the
death I just want to kill you exactly
they want to kill you if they can't kill
you they might be like oh there were
problems at work out here they said
about like mountain lions I want seen on
that I don't know anything I don't want
me and I but if you get attacked you're
supposed to fight back I heard because
my girl right now she's from the
Northwest area and we went on this like
once and so she told me while we were
there like oh you know they have
mountain lion they had little packets on
how to deal with if you see a mountain
I'm like if you told me that there was
mountain lions here I will not a king
but anyway so I'm gonna I'm reading the
pamphlet and they say if you get big
they usually like the value already back
off yeah yeah throw your arms up in the
air yeah yeah they say if you have a kid
with you you're supposed to pick your
kid up and hold it over your head man
I'm not sure about that yeah I don't
know
but people have killed mountain lions
are four with knives and [ __ ] if you
have a knife and you attack by a girl
man it's possible man that's all I'm
saying is this possible there well you
definitely definitely have to fight you
don't want a wolf to just yell
obscenities if you have to get a
mentality though you just have to lay it
off on what else child it has to be them
attack you like I'm Ashley so I come
from like the mode of like it seems a
hit to be hit kill be killed like people
out here trying to break my bone so like
you have to have kind of a psychotic
mentality well you definitely do to play
NFL yeah
[Applause]
[Music]